[Music]
we were devastated when pixar told us
there would be no more Toy Story after
the third movie but they have just
announced the release of Toy Story 4
stay tuned for all the juicy details
about the fourth toy story movie if you
can't get enough Pixar in your life be
sure to subscribe now let's get to
everything we know about the new Toy
Story 4 movie release date the last toy
story movie was released in 2010 and it
was such an awesome movie Pixar told us
that the franchise was over now that
Andy was headed off to college which was
sad AF but they did leave it sort of
open by giving all our favorite toys to
Bonnie no you got a promise to take good
care of these guys they mean a lot to me
we'd be lying if we said we didn't cry
at the end of that movie the fourth
movie was actually announced in 2015 at
the d23 Expo and since then we haven't
heard much about Toy Story 4 well they
finally announced the release date and
it's not that far away
times have changed since the last movie
was released so of course Pixar director
Josh Cooley made the release date
announcement on Instagram that's where
all the important stuff happened now on
April 20 18 he posted a photo of a giant
red and yellow number 4 made of posted
notes the caption was just the release
date June 21st 2019 we absolutely cannot
wait for the new movie we sure hope June
21st hurries up and gets here we have
been looking for every detail we can
about bugs woody and the gang and who
will definitely keep an eye on Josh
couey's instagrams and more behind the
scenes info it was never supposed to
happen
you may remember how in Toy Story 3 all
the toys were sad that Andy never played
with them anymore but Andy had grown up
and was about to head off to college I'm
calling it guys we're closing up shop
Andy's going to college any day now his
mom first gave the toys to we take care
and then the toys were subjected to a
reign of terror by a purple teddy bear
named lot so they
on their way home in Ames he gave the
toys to a little girl named Bonnie the
storyline from the first two movies was
wrapped up perfectly and creator John
Lasseter agreed in 2013 rumors began
circulating that a fourth movie was in
the works it started after a radio exec
from Columbia tweeted saying that the
movie was slated to be released in 2015
but Disney denied these rumors saying
nothing official was in the works
the creators were really happy with the
third movie and they never wanted to
make another one that didn't live up to
the awesomeness of the first three but
they didn't idea stuck and they couldn't
stop thinking about it they have assured
fans that the new movie will be amazing
we wouldn't expect anything less from
Disney and Pixar late release every year
TV hosts a giant gathering with all the
latest news called the d23 Expo this is
where new projects are announced and
current projects give updates it's a
huge deal and it sounds like it would be
so cool to attend in 2015 a huge
bombshell was dropped to the attendees
of d23 there is a presentation about an
upcoming fourth Toy Story movie then
songwriter Randy Newman performed the
famous song you've got a friend in me
dancers just as the characters and came
out on stage and then real-life green
army men descended from the ceiling epic
is an understatement
but the release date was announced as
June 16 2017 then we heard pretty much
nothing else for two years everyone sort
of forgot about the whole thing until
Josh Cooley announced the new release
date back in April of 2018 production is
way behind and there were some issues
with the screenwriters and it's not like
Pixar hasn't been super busy since 2015
they've released six movies since then
including several sequels like cars
three monsters University finding Dory
and Incredibles - it sure looks like
June 21st 2019 is their real release
date
we hope it doesn't get pushed back even
further Pixar swapped it with
Incredibles - it became pretty clear by
2016 that Toy Story was not going to be
released the following year production
was way behind so they pushed the date
to June 15 2018 1 Pixar sequel did
released on June 16 2017 it was cars 3
which is another huge hit starring
everyone's favorite racecar Lightning
McQueen the production team fell behind
pretty quickly on Toy Story 3
but another much-anticipated foot was
ahead of schedule in 2016
work on Incredibles 2 was moving
steadily along Pixar announced that they
would swap the release dates of
Incredibles 2 and Toy Story 3 everyone
was really excited about that since the
first Incredibles movie was released a
whole 14 years before the sequel and
that's just way too long for such an
awesome movie speaking of first movie
releases did you know the original Toy
Story movie came out in 1995 so by the
time the new movie comes out the Toy
Story franchise will be 24 years old
that makes Andy well into his grown-up
years maybe he will have kids of his own
which other Pixar movie would you like
to see have a sequel
the production team fell behind pretty
quickly on Toy Story 4 pixar announced
that they would swap the release states
of Incredibles 2 and Toy Story 4
returning characters one of the best
parts of the Toy Story movies is the
huge cast of amazing original characters
in the first movie woody is Andy's
favorite toy until he gets the new Buzz
Lightyear spaceman toy there's a ton of
jealousy between the two but they
eventually become friends in the first
film we get to meet Rex the dinosaur
slinky dog ham the piggy bank
mr. Potato Head and Woody's love
interest Bo Peep and people immediately
fell in love with all of these toys Toy
Story 2 introduces several new
characters when woody is stolen by a
retro toy collector we get to meet
Jessie the yodeling cowgirl and Woody's
horse
bullseye Toy Story 3 introduces us to
Barbie and Ken we know that at least
some of these characters are returning
in the new movie according to IMDB Woody
and Buzz will of course be back along
with Bo Peep Jessie slinky dog and
Barbie and since John Ratzenberger the
voice of ham is the only person to voice
a character in every Pixar film it's
safe to bet that ham will return to I'm
fortunately the voice of mr. Potatohead
has passed away but they had replaced
the actor of slinky dog so we still get
the character we are so excited to see
which other characters are returning for
Toy Story 4 brand new character since
every toy story movie has introduced
awesome new characters we are pumped to
meet whatever new characters Toy Story 4
has in store for us so far only one new
character has been announced in 2015
actress Patricia Arquette was confirmed
to be joining the cast of Toy Story 4
Patricia Arquette is a pretty famous
actress she starred on the TV shows
medium and CSI cyber she got really
well-known after starring as the mom in
the movie boyhood in 2013 but she's been
acting since 1987
we know she will do an amazing job in
Toy Story 4 with such an impressive
resume our cat joins such film legends
as Tom Hanks Tim Allen and Joan Cusack
for the animated movie we don't know her
character's name yet but we do know she
is playing a hippie mother what does
that mean is she a toy hippie mother or
is she joining Bonnie and Bonnie's mom
as another human character we have so
many questions Pixar one thing is for
sure this cast is lit there's no way a
movie with this cast could be bad hurry
up June 2019 we cannot wait once know
more about the plot of the new movie
keep watching to find out writer drama
there's been a lot of speculation about
why the release of Toy Story 4 caps
getting pushed back at the same time
there's been a lot of drama with the
writers and a script it's pretty likely
that these two things have a lot to do
with each other
first of all Annie Potts who plays Bo
Peep has set that Pixar scrapped
three-quarters of the original script
and rewrote it she said Pixar movies
usually take two years from start to
finish
but they get a lot more creative Liberty
than live-action movies then two of the
original writers rashida Jones and wil
McCormick left the project in fall of
2017
they cited creative and philosophical
differences but there was a lot of
speculation about their leave shortly
after this John Lasseter the Pixar
creative director went on a six-month
leave after many women complained about
his behavior
one article said that this is the reason
rashida Jones left but denied that
Lasseter was the cause of her departure
now writers Stephanie Folsom has two
and overriding the script she's got a
pretty impressive background so we know
this movie will be awesome we sure hope
all the drama Pixar has died down and no
one feels uncomfortable anymore the
gang's all there a lot of familiar faces
are returning to Toy Story 4 and it's
more than just our favorite characters
John Lasseter is back from his six-month
leave and he's still credited as the
executive producer and he is one of the
four geniuses behind the original story
of the new movie Andrew Stanton is back
as one of the writers he has worked on
all four toy story films you may also
recognize his name for wall-e and
Finding Nemo Pete docter best known for
up and inside out is also returning he
wrote for the first two Toy Story movies
but he did not write the third one we
encourage is the genius behind Pixar's
Coco he edited the first two Toy Story
films and wrote for the third movie
often returning this composer and
songwriter Randy Newman we sure hope he
writes another great pit like you've got
a friend in me with all these familiar
faces we know Toy Story 4 will have the
same great story music and animation
that we love from the first three we
already know that there is one new
writer and director Josh Cooley is new
to the franchise we bet these fresh
faces adds a new life to the story are
you as excited as we are full circle
Toy Story was the very first Pixar film
to be created
[Music]
it was a huge hit and it was a huge deal
because computer animation was such a
new field and it's a classic both
sequels were a huge hit as well
Toy Story 3 which debuted 15 years after
the original brought in a whole new
generation 2 loved woody buzz and the
gang now all these kids are growing up
and the awesome world of Toy Story is
being passed on to another generation
Toy Story 4 is also going to be the last
Pixar movie of the decade there are
three untitled Pixar movies in the works
but they are not slated to appear until
2020 and 2021 Toy Story started the
Pixar journey and round out the decade -
how cool is that we saw an D storyline
comes full circle in the third movie now
we could to see what happens in the toys
new life with Bonnie
it's pretty amazing then even when it's
been nearly two dozen years Toy Story is
still so exciting this movie will be a
huge hit because the franchise has more
than twenty years worth of loyal fans
what's the story so what is the new
movie about anyway first after the movie
was announced in 2015
Disney teased us with a tiny to bed the
new movie focuses on woody and Bo peeps
love story
you may remember that Bo Peep was
missing from Toy Story 3 she had been
sold in the yard sell poor woody the new
movie centers around getting Bo Peep
back and if we know woody in the game we
have no doubt they will succeed in
finding her it's pretty creative because
the first three movies centered around
the toys relationships with Andy now
they live with Bonnie and they are ready
to be reunited with Bo Peep Toy Story 4
is a standalone film so you don't need
to remember all the plot details from
the first three movies who are we
kidding
we'll be binge watching these movies
right before the new ones come out and
probably a few times before speaking of
Bo Peep
John Lasseter said she and her story are
inspired by his wife Nancy how adorable
is that will you be watching the new Toy
Story 4 movie let us know in the
comments and that's it for the scoop on
Toy Story 4 be sure to like this video
and subscribe to keep up with all things
Disney and Pixar see you later
[Music]